well i'm delighted that nazanin anushay  and morad  have all been released by the iranians  and that nazanin and anushay will return  back home to the uk  this has been an appalling ordeal  for nazanin anushay morad and their  families who had suffered greatly and  i'm sure  everybody across the uk is delighted  uh that they have been released  and will be celebrating that fact why  now  well we've been working hard over the  last six months to ensure  that we were able to secure the release  of these  detainees  nazanin  and make sure  that they are able to  uh and this is happening for nazanin and  anushay make sure they're able to return  back to the uk  i just want to say  my sympathies with the families for what  they've suffered  over this appalling time and i'm  delighted to be welcoming them back to  the uk later today thank you